mais moi j'entends une nécessité de
transformer justement le parlement pour
qu'on ait les conditions de travail qui
permettent d'être plus efficace ça
rejoint le point un précédent sur la loi
landes
l'exemple typique les sénateurs ne
disent pas la même chose dans
l'hémicycle que à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle qu'à l'extérieur de
l'hémicycle
la réalité elle est assez simple là
aussi il faut partir des constats on a 4
millions de mal logés en france
est ce que vous savez avant les
questeurs aime bien les chiffres combien
de budget sur le logement on met par
jour 136 millions d'euros donc c'est ça
ne veut pas dire que c'est trop d'argent
mais ça veut dire que c'est de l'argent
qui n'est pas efficace qui ne qui ne
fonctionne pas on ne peut pas avoir 136
millions d'argent millions d'euros par
dont deux d'argent public dépensés sur
le logement avec un résultat aussi aussi
mauvais pour être très clair 4 millions
de mal-logés c'est juste intolérables et
donc tout le travail de julien de
normandie et de jacques mézard c'est
justement retrouver les souplesses qui
permettent de reconstruire
on a trois millions de logements vides
également donc c'est tout le sujet c'est
on peut faire le lien aussi avec le
numérique le le le on parle de
déconnexion de territoires souvent mais
le numérique je viens de normandie a
trouvé un accord avec les opérateurs
télécoms du prêt de 4 milliards d'euros
supportés par les opérateurs télécoms
pour raccrocher pour rattraper les 11
millions de français qui sont
aujourd'hui exclues du numérique donc
moi quand j'entends ces postures cg
plutôt pour le coup ça me fait penser
plutôt à justement la déconnexion des
sénateurs par rapport à l'or noir
on a entendu au début de la discussion
générale au sénat la rapporteure du
texte dominique estrosi sassone était
d'accord avec vous sur le constant
disant votre diagnostic était le monde
mais elle disparaît texte ne répond pas
ça fait attendre les satellites ça fait
30 ans que tout le monde est d'accord
sur le diagnostic mais elle dit que ce
texte ne répond pas à la problématique
elle parle de valse-hésitation constante
est ce que c'est le cas ce n'est pas le
cas ça fait trente trois décennies vous
savez moi j'ai 39 ans ça fait trois
décennies que j'entends ça le on est
tous d'accord sur le diagnostic c'est
intolérable etc
on va pas refaire la même chose on va
pas heureux réemployer les mêmes
solutions qui n'ont pas fonctionné
donc on fait autrement et on va aussi la
tenir nos engagements que ça pèse ou ne
s'apaisent pas là le sujet il ya aussi
j'entends une posture
un positionnement des républicains sur
le sujet au fond pourquoi parce qu'il
n'ya pas de contre-propositions vous les
entendez vous les contre propositions de
laurent wauquiez au delà de la majorité
les républicains au sénat
vous qui aimez les chiffres le
gouvernement prévoit 40 mille ventes de
logements sociaux contre 8000
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est vraiment
atteignable vous êtes optimiste
non on est déterminés là encore une fois
c'est ne pas juste faire des diagnostics
et sans référence au précédent métier du
du du président larcher
c'est pas juste établir des diagnostics
c'est prescrire et soigner et faire
autrement et aussi prendre le sujet en
amont aujourd'hui je vais faut dire 4
millions de mal logés en france c'est
intolérable donc je n'ai pas de doute
sur le fait qu'à la fin le parlement et
le gouvernement trouveront un accord sur
cette ligne directrice et c'est
l'intérêt général c'est l'intérêt de
tous les freins moi juste sur un point
du texte qui a fait des bas rhin 10 % de
logements accessibles aux handicapés
c'est ce que prévoit la loi les
sénateurs ont voté 30% est ce que c'est
un site vous pouvez retenir non mais là
c'est un problème de curseur technique
le sujet n'est pas là remet le sujet
c'est d'envoyer un signal pour dire qu
on assouplit les conditions
c'est comme pour les pylônes justement
jusqu'à l'épisode télécom dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
jusqu'ici il y avait un visa impératifs
des architectes de france même plus
aujourd'hui ça ça permet d'assouplir les
conditions et quand vous écoutez tous
les professionnels ils vous disent
justement que le le 100% avant était
inapplicable et provoqué une
augmentation des prix donc ce qu'on fait
on l'assument c'est autrement 6 et 10 6
et 15 je ne sais pas le dire mais en
tout cas on envoie un signal fort pour
assouplir les choses